you're a [__] hater bro you
privileged assle flying is like wearing
four condoms and trying to enjoy sex
everything sucks about it that's the
perfect way to put
[Music]
it all right I'm pretty sure this might
be something that some of you can relate
to there has been a couple that is
demanding a refund after they were
seated next to a drooling and farting
dog on a 13-hour flight it was Nick Nick
was the ruing farting
dog did someone buy a ticket for the dog
and then the dog was just do you have to
buy tickets for a dog I think you do um
I think like over a certain weight limit
how how big they are oh like if they
don't fit in your lap in like a bag I
think I've seen people literally like
straight up fly with the Husky between
their legs yeah like that's their
remember the the the whole period where
everyone had emotional support animal
yeah like that was their emotional and
then the airlines regretted that
decision right cuz it's just a playful
of people with dogs on biggest dogs
you've ever seen cuz dude if your dog is
well behaved and it's fine then it's all
good I rather have a stinky dog than a
guy that [__] his pants next to me yeah
that's pretty rough
too doesn't happen right it's happened
in in uh on the way from Japan to La
we're talking about the wait no no no it
was on my flight there was a guy behind
me and something just smelled like [__]
like an old guy he was older yeah but he
wasn't the
grandpa I have fought him yeah he was
like 50 50 60 and I heard people in the
back like oh [__] I'm suffering so hard
and I'm like what happened and then I
think he pooped his pants do you feel
more sorry for that guy or do you feel
sorry for the people around him oh I I
felt sorry for all of us but the
Japanese people are probably really
polite and they didn't bring it up they
didn't say anything they were just
saying like they're just saying like
they were just saying like I'm suffering
and then he goes yeah hang in there
buddy like I heard their overheard their
conversation this is on the flight to
Japan no from Japan to La oh that's a
long flight yeah oh dude I couldn't even
do a I can't even do like a a window
seat like like never mind [__]
someone [__] their pants like that's you
can't do a window seat I'm right there
with you I Dole yeah I used to always
get window but I get Aisle all the time
now he sitting in the bed I'm always
window seat I get Aisle cuz it's I pee a
lot that's too oh I get window cuz I
want to lean on something and when I'm
in the aisle and I'm like asleep and the
[__] cart like hits my knee or some
[__] that destroys well we could sit
next to each other then cuz you're going
to have window all the time yeah Nick's
in the middle so that we can in the
middle [__] his
pants
should I'll fall asleep on one of your
shoulders so just watch out bro his
mouth open too not even closed so yeah
this was a Singapore Airlines flight 13
hours from Paris to Singapore the
couples demanding a refund uh their
names are Gil and Warren press they said
they were sat next to a drooling and
farting dog in the flight and they ended
up switching seats because it was too
much to bear well if they swapped seats
then why they swapped seeds but now
they're demanding refunds because you
know that's [__] Fu [__] dude if
you already got switched and your
problem was solved then what the [__]
yeah yeah that is [__] Honestly
though I [__] hate Airlines so give
any people their money back you know
what I mean I [__] hate Airlines
what's worse is there a single one that
you do like um cuz they all kind of do
su except for are pretty good Singapore
is actually pretty yeah I heard that one
Singapore is Bomb their service is
amazing I remember there was that one
story of a really big dude that was in
the bathroom and he took a [__] and he
needed to help wipe his ass and he
traumatized a flight attendance cuz he
asked them to wipe his ass but he was
being hella demanding about it well the
Asian airlines are down for anything
they'll like get on their knees and like
oh would you like a blanket they did it
but they were like traumatized
afterwards and it was it main news yeah
he looked like Santa Claus Joe knows
every [__] story on airlines by the way
that's two for two I do hate flying
though I hate it's the worst it's
literally the worst is that because
you're so big no I hate being in one
place I hate being squished next to
people and then you got to have this
like okay who gets the arm resting and I
I try to be nice but what if you get
business class though then is way better
it's better it still sucks no no what
cuz like I've flown a decent amount of
business class in the past couple years
um I flew I flew from Europe and it does
not get any better because it's cool for
like class sucks let me tell
you there's nothing the [__] that's why
I only fly PJs now yeah exactly no but
honestly and I will assume I've only
been on it a couple times with 50 like I
50 can I borrow your jet again I can
assume that that eventually gets like
[__] I got you know what I mean I got to
get like I feel like you just get used
to everything and you like I saw a
picture of the rock eating a steak on a
private jet while someone was shaving
his head and I'm like that's pretty
tight is he not going to get the [__]
hair follicles in his steak but it's
multitasking that and he's like I can't
wait till this flight's over this sucks
I must be a dumbass because every two
weeks I fly back and forth 5 hours from
Hawaii to here and on top of that every
single time I fly even if it's like
shitty ass Frontier I get excited bro I
don't dude I I envy you I'm not kidding
I envy you it makes me feel like so it I
have this nostalgic feeling of when I
was like 12 flying with my mom to San
Francisco to see my uncle all those
feelings I had as a kid every single
time without fail I get them I I'm the
same way and and it gets even better cuz
business class like I flew business
class this time over here and I surprise
myself cuz I'll book out like 3 to four
months worth of flights and I'll
randomly place like business class in
there so sometimes it'll just be like oo
what do I got today you know and it's
like oh it's just economy all right but
I fly so much that on the day when I um
check in they go oh you've been upgraded
to premium so ooh premium nice and one
day it's like ah [__] I got I didn't get
my sandwich today and then it's like oh
I got business class they're going to
feed me you know wait wait why do you
fly that often I I live in Hawaii oh
[__] so he comes here every two weeks
yeah and I fly here every two weeks and
and then I have a house in Vegas so
don't you live in Vegas whatever yeah I
do how do you like Hawai you love living
there I love it yeah yeah I [__] love
it yeah I assume if you're flying here
every but I live in Vegas too so then
yeah and yeah so I hate I hate the whole
process everything about it going to the
air uh the [__] airport and I hate
I'm like trust me I'm not going to blow
this place up and then and then you know
sometimes you get TSA PR yeah we believe
you but you know you get TSA but then
sometimes there randomly there is no TSA
Pre that day and I'm like but
[__] I have TSA Pre just let me
go in here why do I have to go in this
2hour line This Way
every single step of the way I hate it's
the work I'm on I I I wish I had what
you guys have because I [__] hate
I'll say this I'm like Joe I hate all of
the other [__] I hate the [__] pre
like the the the TSA [__] and you hate
getting the luggage tags cuz it's like
anxiety until you get on the plane
that's what I love the feeling of when
you get to sit and chill you're like
okay now I could just relax and there's
something amazing of when you get on
that plane and that feels better than
your own couch at home of course you're
not going from [__] apples and
oranges that's what you're that's what
you're comparing though no you're not
one is traveling there's like a goal at
the you already know it's going to suck
I prer I prefer to like [__] teleport
It's morphin
time yeah yeah
yeah dude he's like oh I didn't know
super powers were on the
table the rules change here all the time
also I don't know what it is but flying
helps me work and think focused like I
can [__] just go on and you can't do
anything else flying helps me not work
in think that's when I'm like oh I can't
take your calls for 13 hours you know
well it's a different kind of work I
feel like it's a lot of creative or just
my I think better I don't know why yeah
maybe it clears like the ADD and then
like super zoned in yeah I don't know
flying allows me to finally binge watch
[__] that I like doubt that's another
fun thing too one of my favorites
because like I feel so guilty at home B
watching [__] or like trying to catch up
on stuff I H all of it so even with
working I do work but then that's like
My Plan F you know I'm I open an email
and the [__] Wi-Fi sucks so it's like
I'm like [__] I should have just checked
this at home let's watch a movie let's
watch a movie and then you're over here
and then you're like oh no no it's not
clear anymore uh it's getting dark like
you have to literally be right here cuz
versus like 80 in TV like everything
sucks you're a [__] hater bro you
privileged [__] flying is like
wearing four condoms and trying to enjoy
sex everything sucks about it that's the
perfect way to put it every everything
they try to adapt it to is just the
shittiest like it's like you know like
appreciate that you're moving at like
600 mph in [__] air you idiot you
have no you have this is teleportation
is this you you get [__] the
headphones they like oh surround sounds
so hey don't p with my cord oh the
surround sounds so you're participating
in the miracle of flight as a human
being and traveling across the planet
I'd rather just stay at
home but I get that too though I will
say the worst thing about flying is uh
when you fall asleep and you're you're
like asleep and you wake up you're like
oh my God that must have been like 8
hours it's like 12 minutes like what the
[__] actually second worst thing okay
I'm like I'm like this is worse than
being hijacked
okay this thing is not being able to
fall asleep I can't fall asleep for the
life of me you don't take nothing before
you go on I can't do it you don't
participate like it doesn't matter how
tired I am how long the flight is drugs
help the plane ride yeah they do you
love flying you love I don't love fly
but I'm just saying because I have to do
it so frequently I'm not [__] I hate
everything about everything and this is
four condoms of SE rather travel by
plane or would you travel by you know
bus everything else well Bart also gets
M don't you get migraines not anymore
but almost every that's why I drive here
so much i' rather just be in a car
really yeah yeah yeah so you would
rather do 3 hours of driving than 45
minutes of flying because it's not 45
minutes difference it's 5 hours anyways
yeah the difference between Vegas I
totally understand cuz I still also
enjoy road trip so I'd rather drive than
fly to Vegas I like drive to Vegas too
but we're talking about I got to take my
shoes off before I go in my car like
transcontinental I don't we're talking
over and over pretty Chinese take this
out trust me I'm not going to blow this
place up just [__] just trust me I'm
not going to blow I don't have to do
anything when I get in my car you need
to get GSA pre-checked dude I do that's
what I said why you taking off your
shoes I have it and they'll still go I'm
so sorry what you also look like trouble
I have clear I have global entry I have
TSA Pre have all the whole I want to
make it convenient I go there like oh
you're Asian you're too cross-eyed the
[__] clear doesn't work today I'm
like of course it wouldn't work today
that's cuz you have a microwave in your
carry-on he's like I got to make sure
this chickens heat up halfway through
the plate they're like sure maybe but I
got all of that and then sometimes
they're still like I'm sorry you got to
go on the regular line I'm like why do I
pay for all this [__] [__] so fun
I've never heard somebody have that
problem who has all I have clear global
entry and TSA proof I also think he's a
complainer I do all of it I travel for
military I travel with my family I we
used to do a [__] ton of shows and Joe
has never heard me complain cuz if it's
part of the job I just do it but right
now I hate it he's traveling with Gio
and ta and Gio and ta make it through
the TSA Pre he has to still go through
the regular line he gets the [__] in at
this you can't find your name on the TSA
pre-check well you know what good good
that it doesn't work out for you okay
[__] for every single
[Music]
time